-Were there things of doing
a comedy with Seth Rogen,
were there moments
where you were doing things
that you couldn't believe
you were doing,
based on all your previous work
up to that moment?
I know it's not in the film,
but did you do some singing?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-I apologize.
Well, I don't.
You're never gonna see it, so...
-Gotcha.
Is that because
you underperformed?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, okay.
-And by the way,
I acknowledged it.
I told them, I warned them.
-You sang so bad,
it couldn't be in a comedy.
-They wanted to --
[ Laughter ]
It's true!
-[ Laughs ]
-They wanted to do this scene
of me singing karaoke with
the Japanese Prime Minister.
-Uh-huh.
-And it was, like,
a Smash Mouth song.
-Right. Can I guess?
Was it "All Star"?
-Yeah.
-It was that Smash Mouth song?
Yeah.
-And I couldn't sing that.
-You couldn't sing "All Star"?
-I couldn't sing "All Star."
I was --
I'm a terrible singer.
And the thing is, is --
not even skill.
I just -- it's the thing that
makes me the most anxious.
-Uh-huh.
-I don't like it.
-Sure.
-Like, I would rather share,
like, state secrets than sing.
-Yeah. Look, I'm no fan of it,
either, so I'm with you 100%.
-Yeah.
-And I think karaoke
somehow makes it worse.
-Especially with people
who are really good.
-Yeah.
-They're just looking at you
like you're an idiot.
-Well, also, karaoke is like --
It's kind of like training
wheels to actual singing.
-Yeah.
-So it's like being bad
on a bike with training wheels.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "I crashed the bike."
They're like,
"It had training wheels."
I'm like, "I still crashed."
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know what happened.
It was super bad."
-I feel so [bleep]
about myself right now.
-No, no.
I'm with you, I'm with you.
-Wow. I get it.
No, I get it.
I'm gonna remember that.
That's really --
A training wheels, yeah.
-You --
We share something in common.
We are both fans of Rihanna.
-Yes! Yes, yeah.
-And you share
something else with her,
which is you guys
have the same publicist.
-Which is tough.
-Yeah.
-That's tough, because I get it.
I mean, that's --
Like, you want your publicist
to like you.
Like you want to like think
that your publicist thinks
that you're worth
putting out there in the world.
And that has to come
from a very authentic place.
It's hard when your other client
is somebody like Rihanna.
-Yeah.
-Like, your coolest --
But I never thought --
I always
really sincerely thought
that my publicist
really loved me.
-Sure.
-And then --
-I'm sure they do, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
-So, for my birthday, she always
sends me, like, a little text.
And she just sends --
Usually, it's just like,
"Happiest birthday."
Or, she didn't even
write "birthday."
She just wrote "B-day."
-Uh-huh.
-And then, I got --
Like, a couple of months ago,
I got something in the mail.
I came home,
and it was a T-shirt.
And she -- Rihanna had made a
T-shirt of the birthday greeting
that my publicist gave her,
which literally was like,
"To my favorite,
most favorite client ever."
[ Laughter ]
"Have the best --"
It was just, like, so...
[ Laughter ]
And Rihanna wrote
in the following e-mail,
"I'm making a T-shirt of this
and sending it to Charlize,"
and I don't think
my publicist, Amanda,
ever thought
that was gonna happen.
-And this is for real.
-But Amanda [bleep] --
Rihanna says --
-You brought it.
-Yeah.
-This is a real thing
that Rihanna had made
to burn you.
-Rihanna made this for me, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, I hope
you're having a blast."
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
-That is -- That's really great.
-No, I know. Right?
Made me feel great.
-It's really funny.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I guess, you know --
I was like, "That's really nice
for Rihanna to do that,"
but I guess
she's got T-shirt money, right?
[ Laughter ]
-I think she has,
but she took the time
to tell her assistant
to make me a T-shirt,
and that is really cool.
-That's so nice of her.
-That is really cool.
-Hey, thanks for being here.
It's always such
a delight talking to you.
-Thank you for having me.